Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Du hast Themen mitgebracht. Na dann leg mal los.
Naja, wir müssen schon über Jeffrey Epstein sprechen. Du verfolgst das sehr regel oder wie sieht dein Medienkonsum da aus?
Ich habe, es gibt ja immer das Thema und dann das mediale Dings dazu. Und ich frag mich die ganze Zeit, ob sie wirklich so katastrophal dumm sind oder ob es eine Strategie gibt. Und die einzige Strategie, von der ich glaube, dass sie so, aber das wäre auch total erhinnrissig, dass man jetzt einfach alles veröffentlicht, weil man gerade denkt, ja so in 25 Prozent der Amtszeit hofft man, dass es bei 35 Prozent dann absch und bei 75 Prozent und dann sind Wahlen und so weiter und so fort. Also dass man einfach so einen Zeitpunkt wählt, wo man sagt, nee bis November ist noch so und so lang und so weiter.
Und ich glaube, das wird ja auch so kommuniziert, dass man sagt, mehr gibt es auch nicht, mehr gibt es nicht zu veröffentlichen, weitere Infos wird es nicht geben.
Und da sage ich, diese Strategie ist so doof, dass ich sie mitmache. Also sobald mir irgendwas wieder unterkommt, wo ich denke, wow, nochmal ein neuer Ding, nochmal neu irgendwie, mache ich einfach eine Story draus. Weil ich denke, das wird ja nicht aufgehen. Nur weil die das als Idee haben, dass man jetzt so langsam die Temperatur erhöht und dann ist irgendwann so, ah ja gut, okay, wir haben uns dran gewöhnt. Also ich glaube in dem Falle wirklich nicht an den Gewöhnungseffekt.
Ja, also diese...
Die regelbasierte Ordnung.
Ja, also diese ganze marktliberale Ideologie wird hier sehr gut analysiert und wirklich auch anhand der Institutionen gezeigt, wie es funktioniert. Das ist also das Buch, über das wir gemeinsam diskutieren. Außerdem gibt es von mir wieder ein Musik-Tipp, Klavier-Trio. Dann fragen wir uns, gibt es einen neuen faschistischen Körper? Und wenn ja, wie sieht er aus? Dagmar Herzog hat dazu ein Buch geschrieben, dann lange schon angekündigt, jetzt endlich Thomas Wagner, Wege aus der Gewalt, Impulse für neues politisches Denken. Gibt es also eine Möglichkeit, jenseits des Sozialstaats zu denken? Außerdem blicken wir auf die Streaming-Plattform MUBI, die sich enorm entwickelt hat, aber jetzt doch auch mit einigen Ärgernissen zu kämpfen hat. Und wir schauen uns noch an, wie eigentlich Öl von Venezuela nach China gelangt. Da gibt es eine Recherche aus dem Handelsblatt.
Brauchen wir keine Pipeline? Nein. Okay, sehr gut. Das nicht über Politik reden Buch schieben wir nochmal auf für ein anderes spektakuläres Buch. Ich war so gefesselt, selten war ich so gefesselt von einem Buch. Ich habe es gehört, von der Autorin selbst gelesen, Julia Anders Organisch. Es kam schon im August, ich habe es gar nicht mitbekommen. Aber sie hat nach damit Charme zehn Jahre als Ärztin hinter sich gebracht und hat jetzt ein neues Buch vorgelegt. Das ist wirklich ein Spektakel. Und sagen wir mal so, unter den Gesichtspunkten, hinter den Wir, der Körper im Faschismus, der Körper als Sinngebung fürs Leben, die KI hat keinen Körper, was bedeutet das alles ja? Wird mir richtig gut aufgeklärt. Dann stelle ich zwei Texte gegenüber, die New York Times. In search of a platonic co-parent. Leute nutzen es nicht nur um eine Datingplattform, sondern sie suchen auch Leute, mit denen sie Kinder großziehen können. Und sie sagen ausdrücklich, ich will schon weiter rumdaten und so weiter, mir geht es hier nur um die Kindererziehung. Und das gleichen wir danach ab mit diesem neuen Text von der Heritage Foundation. Saving America by Saving the Family. 150 Seiten Policy Paper. Ich weiß nicht, also die drehen mittlerweile so am Rat, das ist wirklich unglaublich. Und zum Abfluss Dario Amodei, der Anthropik-Chef. Von dem haben wir ja schon diesen Text geschrieben, Machine of Loving Grace oder sowas, wo so die utopischen, wir werden alles 40 mal schneller entwickelt und so weiter und so fort. Er hat jetzt einen zweiten Text geschrieben, den hat er ja auch da wo es schon so ein bisschen angekündigt. The Adolescence of Technology. Dieser Text ist sehr lang, was ich witzig finde, da wir alle wissen, also schon ohne KI schreiben diese Leute diese Texte nicht selber, mit KI und vor allem mit eigener, wissen wir ungefähr, wer diesen Text geschrieben hat. Also habe ich ihn auch von Claude lesen lassen. Wir lesen also nur, was Claude mir gesagt hat, was in dem Text drin steht.
Und darauf vertraust du, dass Claude das kann?
Also wenn mich Claude jetzt belügt, dann wurden wir halt hin ins Licht geführt und der Amodei hat über was anderes geschrieben und ich frage mich, ja und? Es ist ja nur ein literarischer Beitrag, was?
Was heißt nur ein literarischer Beitrag?
Naja, der Typ weiß, also der hat für sich entschieden, dass er seine Ideen über Technologie in die Welt bringt. Ja. Ich frage mich, warum schreibt er überhaupt Texte? Ehrlich gesagt ist das auch bei Palantir und The Technological Republic so. Dieses Buch, da wir es sehr kritisch lesen können, schadet ja eher dieser Mission, weil es doch sehr viel Skepsis unterfüttert, die man Palantir entgegenbringen kann. Also wir hätten sehr viel weniger Argumente, dem Bayerischen oder baden-württembergischen Grünen nochmal zu sagen, warum sie Palantir, wenn er das einfach nicht geschrieben hätte.
Ja, genau.
Genauso wie zu Guttenberg jetzt Bundeskanzler wäre, hätte er einfach keine Dessertation geschrieben. Also Texte können auch schädlich sein für die Leute. Und in deren Sicht finde ich es schon witzig, dass er auch nochmal im Sinne von für ihn nur Literatur vorlegt.
Gut bei Guttenberg ist es, glaube ich, etwas anders. Da geht es um Zertifikate zu erhalten. Aber hier in diesen Fällen möchte ich jetzt ganz klar sagen, diese Leute sind ja so von sich überzeugt, dass sie eigentlich so eine Verfassung schreiben. Ja, so muss man das eigentlich sehen. Sie so, wie würde ich jetzt eine Verfassung schreiben? Ich stelle mir mal folgendermaßen die Welt vor, ich schreib es mal genau nieder. Und so machen das die ja eigentlich, dass sie sagen, also auch Antriessen Horowitz, die auch immer solche langen Texte herausgeben, die schreiben gerne so auf, wie sie die Gesellschaft haben. Also man könnte dann sagen, aber wir haben doch hier schon Grundgesetz rumliegen. Ja, nee, interessiert mich nicht. Ich habe mir jetzt eine eigene Verfassung.
Okay, dann frame ich es anders. Superreiche, supermächtige, super schöne Leute lassen sich morgens eine Morgenlage vorlegen. Wir kennen sehr viele Leute, die daran arbeiten, Mick zum Beispiel, die so eine Morgenlage aufbreiten. Also es gibt Leute, die lesen wirklich, was in der Welt steht und andere kriegen dann so ein Deserat, sag ich schon, so ein Konzentrat.
Und du machst das jetzt im Prinzip mit der KI auch, wie die Mächtigen sagst, leg mir mal eine Morgenlage vor.
Also ich bin sehr gespannt, falls es Diskussionen dazu gibt. Also die Kritik nehme ich gerne entgegen, dass ich ja den Text von Dario Amodai nicht vollständig über meine Augen konsumiert habe, während wir alle wissen, wer der Autor ist und welche Technologie er in Anschlag bringt und so weiter. Also für die auch witzig.
Das alles werden wir gleich diskutieren, besprechen, empfehlen im Salon. Den Salon kann man hören, wenn man ein Abo abschließt. Es ist also ein Zusatzinhalt zu Die Neuen Zwanziger. Manchmal muss man es noch mal dazu sagen, weil manche glauben auch, es ist ein einfach getrennte Podcast oder so. Nein, es ist ein Zusatzinhalt zu Die Neuen Zwanziger und das ist auch der einzige Weg, Die Neuen Zwanziger, die ja frei verfügbar sind, zu unterstützen. Wir freuen uns, wenn ihr das tut. Das ist möglich über Apple, da kann man das mit einem Klick abonnieren, kommt dann auch zu den alten Folgen. Man kann, wenn man schon bei Patreon angemeldet ist, dort auch ein Abo abschließen bei Die Neuen Zwanzigern. Wir empfehlen allerdings Steady. Dort hat man die beste Übersicht auf wirklich das Gesamtachief und mit drei Euro im Monat ist man dabei und hat dann aber auch immer Zugang zu allen alten Folgen und zusätzlich natürlich auch zu den Live-Salons, die wir in Frankfurt veranstalten. Auch die werden ja aufgezeichnet.
Genau.
Und man kann sich, wenn ich das noch anfinde, auch schon eine andere Besprechung anhören. Wir haben nämlich von Patrick Hartz-Marsch schon mal ein Buch gelesen, nämlich Kampf der Nationen. Da geht es um den tollen Wettbewerb innerhalb Europas und wir gehen jetzt quasi so auf den globalen Rahmen und schauen uns, wie der Wettbewerb stattfindet.
Das ist dann der Februar 2022-Salon. Claude hat mir nämlich eine schöne Übersicht gebaut. Ich kann sofort alle meine Notizen reinkommen. So, was ich sagen wollte, weil du sagst, das ist der Zusatzinhalt, das stimmt. Aber wenn ihr bei Steady euch einen Account macht, dann das Geld bezahlt und dort Zugriff auf den Salon habt, dann ist der Salon sozusagen ein eigenständiger Podcast. Also wenn ihr dann in die Apple Podcast App geht, weil das eure Lieblings-Podcast-App ist und ihr nehmt den RSS-Feed des Salons, den ihr von Steady bekommt und ihr tragt den in der Apple Podcast App ein, dann ist in der Apple Podcast App der Salon ein eigener Podcast. Ihr seht dann trotzdem immer noch die von Apple angebotenen Salon-Folgen im allgemeinen Podcast. Aber das darf euch bitte nicht länger verwirren. Ich habe jetzt ein paar E-Mails dazu geschrieben. Apple weiß nicht, dass ihr Salon-Abonnenten seid. Euch wird also das dort nicht einfach ausgeblendet, sondern das ist halt trotzdem da. Aber ihr habt ja schon den Salon als eigenständigen Podcast. Ihr könnt also diesen teureren Button-Click da einfach ignorieren, denn es ist ja derselbe Salon.
Genau. Und man kann dann über diesen RSS-Fit, den man von Steady erhält, generell alles hören. Das heißt, man muss nicht noch zusätzlich Die Neuen Zwanziger noch mal irgendwo anders abonniert haben, sondern es reicht eigentlich. Mit Steady ist man rundum versorgt.
Genau. Wenn ihr bei Steady-Abonnenten seid, könnt ihr überall anders den Podcast ignorieren, denn ihr bekommt ja auch die Monatsfolge ohne Werbung im Salon-Fit dann bei Steady.
Und jetzt noch zum Schluss, wer das gerne lieber verschenken möchte, kann das auch tun. Für ein Jahr kann man via Steady den Salon verschenken. Außerdem freuen wir uns, wenn ihr überhaupt den Salon und Die Neuen Zwanziger weiterempfehlt und den Podcast positiv bewertet. Ich würde sagen, genug der Werbung. Wir gehen jetzt hinein in den Salon.
So ist es.